Debra Tice automobiles delay Yahoo car
Chester Sasha Knopf explains that even
if Jaguar hails from a long sporting
tradition it still has to keep pace with
today's market the f-type tried to
contend with a Porsche the F pace takes
on the SUV segment and the Jaguar XE
claims the mid-sized nish the previous
generation the X type may have been
little more than a spiffed up Mondeo but
the XE has now come into its own the
modified Ford platform for the last
generation has been retired the new XE
is built on land rover's modular
architecture the lightweight
construction makes for a body shell of
only 251 kilos the sedans roofline still
expresses Jaguar design sweeping back
like a coupe a
we tested the EXCI with the 2-liter
four-cylinder turbocharged diesel
putting out 132 kilowatts of power the
only engine offered with all-wheel drive
the top trim our sport branding accents
the dynamic side of the British model it
can hold its own with Audi a4 BMW
3-series
and Mercedes c-class the engine has all
but lost the tick tocking diesel sound
and AdBlue exhaust treatment helps it
meet the euro-6 emissions standard the
all wheel drive version leaps from 0 to
100 km/h and 7.9 seconds reaching a
maximum speed of 225 km/h the torque
vectoring enhances the sporty feel
especially in tight curves braking the
inside wheels independently of each
other an increasing stability even for
abrupt turns
de agua Sasha observes that the Jaguar
XE is billed as a sports sedan and it
drives like one the suspension is
properly sporting without being too
stiff but the electric power steering is
just a bit soft on that point it's
German competitors are nippy I think
Nike go on topics included in the X's
package of active driver assistance
technologies are Elaine keep assist and
a driver condition monitor for added
safety on long hauls an automatic
emergency braking system supports the
adaptive cruise control closing vehicle
sensing and Park Assist also help make
the driver's life easier the last Sascha
points out that the closing vehicle
sensing is sent very differently from
its counterparts and competitors
vehicles it kicks in much earlier so at
first it's not quite clear what all the
beeping is about if it approaches
another car a bit too rapidly it gives a
warning immediately that's like a whole
father bond demisa fought but the floor
if for example a vehicle is parked on
the shoulder in a curve it spots it
immediately as a potential obstacle it's
German competitors warn the driver much
later but much as with the adaptive
cruise control he'd rather have the
option to set the distance himself
Mercedes
beeps too late for his taste and Jaguar
too soon if he could set the distance
himself it would be ideal Kevon bed mr.
tan Vera's Optima
the EXCI maybe the lowest-priced Jaguar
available but it makes no compromises on
the interior the our sport version is
appropriately elegant and dignified
without going too far
it includes such typical Jaguar features
as the booting up of the instruments
when starting at the prints of a button
the shift lever for the 8-speed
automatic transmission rises from the
centre console the driving modes provide
options for more dynamic or more
fuel-efficient styles de água Sasha is
reminded that the Jaguar XE is mid-sized
by the rear seats he can see that
there's not much leg room available in
back though it may be enough for
passengers who are not as tall and
big-boned as he is but he sees the front
seatbacks made of hard plastic as a big
- he's convinced there must be a more
comfortable solution for the writers
knees when they're jammed in here - the
German competitors are only marginally
better dissing Mia come for hot Abba
ohina magaz act the Dogma - Viva Kunduz
or Z up adding to better the awakes in
the back the Jaguar XE can open wide
with a total of 400 55 litres it has
more cargo space than an Audi a4 or a
BMW 3-series little de água still he
believes that Jaguar XE will not have an
easy time of it in Germany with the
mid-size segment well covered by German
car makers OD BMW and Mercedes have long
since divided up the midsize pie but the
XE would definitely be a good choice for
car buyers looking for a more individual
set of wheels
and Germany this entry-level jag starts
at thirty six thousand four hundred
fifty euros low enough to inspire more
than a few to become owners of this big
cat